peu
[Musique]
et bien qu est-ce que c'est mon dieu
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un schmilblick
vous le savez depuis hier soir depuis
que notre ami pierre dac nous en a donné
une définition assez confuse d'ailleurs
c'est à dire un objet un objet dont vous
devez trouver ou l'utilisation ou le nom
très exact soit ce schmilblick et bien
regardez le à nouveau je crois que c'est
quand même très important c'est
l'essentiel du jeu moi je vous dit
bonsoir bien sûr amis de toute la france
et ami de strasbourg plus
particulièrement ému de strasbourg vous
allez voir quelques instants pourquoi de
moi je l'espère et revenons sur ce
schmilblick
ce schmilblick vous l'avez sûrement vu
un jour ou l'autre
peut-être pas celui là d'ailleurs mais
un autre exactement pareil certains le
voient souvent et j'ajouterais
d'ailleurs que d'autres le voient tous
les jours c'est la station régionale de
lille il a choisi pour la soumettre le
soumettre vous exactement ce schmilblick
ce nom dont vous allez j'espère devenir
très familier à la sagacité des
téléspectateurs de la france entière et
aujourd'hui ce sont les téléspectateurs
de strasbourg qui vont pouvoir tenter
leur chance alors j'espère que nous
avons strasbourg c'est formidable ce
merveilleux et quelques instants eh bien
ils étaient schmilblick et le vannes oc
existe alors pour encourager nos avis de
strasbourg si vous le permettez je vais
dès maintenant à la seconde même et
c'est un des principes importants du jeu
mettre de l'argent dans la cagnotte du
schmilblick
regardez ce merveilleux petites oreilles
la progression est toujours 200 francs
ce sera le seul donc je ferai d'ailleurs
au schmilblick les autres ce sera grâce
à vous que ils vont venir
alors maintenant il y à 100 francs dans
la cagnotte qu'est ce que ce schmilblick
avoue strasbourg avoue gérard brianti
que nous sommes à strasbourg
effectivement la nuit commence à tomber
sur la ville nous sommes très exactement
devant la maison de l'horreur tf il y à
des spectateurs en face de moi et il ya
des candidats à ma droite 19 candidats
très exactement je pense qu'il eût que
s'il en vient d'autres en cours
d'émission
nous essaierons de les faire passer ce
sera bien sûr une question de temps je
précise que jacques solness et dans le
public il a préféré
c'était en coulisses ce soir alors si
vous voulez bien nous allons tous sud
après le premier candidat d'accord ah
oui mais attendez attendez attendez
combien il y a deux candidats d'inscrits
dis-je
et maintenant nous allons voir dans quel
ordre les candidats vont être appelés à
donner et surtout l'honneur au premier
la première définition du schmilblick
alors attention monsieur ou madame qui
allait être la première où le premier à
nous donner cette définition c'est le
départ du jeu on a tous un peu le coeur
qui bat vous allez me poser une question
est ce que par exemple le public se
mange ça sert à manger enfin voyez ce
que je veux dire quelque chose d'aussi
vague
si je vous réponds oui et seulement si
je vous réponds oui vous avez le droit
de donner le nom d'un schmilblick celui
que vous croyez être le bon et dans ce
cas ci c'est vrai vous emporter le total
du montant qui n'est pas gros par contre
si je vous dis non je vous dis au revoir
merci à la prochaine fois voilà c'est
clair alors attention pour 12 minutes
maintenant
chronomètre pour la première fois le jeu
du schmilblick part sur les antennes de
la rtf et c'est le candidat numéro
numéro numéro 11 je crois qui a
l'honneur d'ouvrir le feu avoue
strasbourg avoue qu'en dit la numéro six
voix le candidat numéro qui a gravi les
trois marches qui permet d'arriver
jusqu'au micro monsieur votre nom le
provost gérard strasbourg votre question
est ce que le schmilblick faut servir un
sportif ou le schmilblick ne peut pas
servir un sportif mais la première
question est déjà embarrassante n'est ce
pas jean marc je crois que il y as
rapport mais alors vraiment très très
très très lointain avec le sport mais ça
ne doit pas servir un sportif par
conséquent monsieur je suis obligé de
vous dire merci au deuxième candidat le
candidat numéro 1 1 as le large et zuber
c'est une candidate d'ailleurs qui
arrive
bonjour madame mademoiselle chanel est
ce que le jury se peut s'utiliser en cui
dans la cuisine répété moi comment vous
dites le mot schmiel alizés schmilblick
assaillent m
en alsace et parce qu'il ya un nom du
bus cru est ce que ça me servira dans la
cuisse dans la cuisine absolument pas
mademoiselle je suis désolé non merci
troisième candidat le numéro 19
le candidat suivant il arrive que
monsieur roll strasbourg en france et
strasbourg est ce que le schmilblick
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser le
schmilblick couramment oui je crois
qu'on peut utiliser le schmilblick
couramment dans la mesure où vous avez
besoin du schmilblick
sinon je ne pense pas que vous quel est
votre profession monsieur pardon j'avais
votre professeur étudiant non alors vous
n'utilisez pas le schmilblick couramment
je suis désolé pour vous et je suis
encore plus désolé pour la cagnotte du
schmilblick
rien dans la cagnotte le candidat numéro
10 maintenant le candidat numéro 10 pts
quel âge as-tu 13,1 mais il me semblait
que dans ce jeu on pouvait jouer qu'à
partir de la majorité sur tulle avec toi
c'est pas nous la montrer c c'est une
vérité d'autorisation oui tu peux jouer
alors ton nom de toute façon fischer
thierry judicaire la question est ce que
je suis blinkx employée dans une maison
le schmilblick peut pas employer dans
une maison donne moi ton prénom mon
lapin thierry thierry et bien terry
n'ont franchement pas mais je pense
qu'on va demander à notre réalisateur de
remontrer une fois le schmilblick
regarde le bien et si tu as déjà vu ça
dans ta maison dans la maison d'un des
petits camarades alors tu viendras nous
le dit regarde non voilà le schmilblick
à nouveau sur les écrans alors que nous
appelons maintenant le concurrent numéro
le concurrent numéro 10 c'est sur votre
écran pousse un petit peu thiery voilà
concurrent numéro 10 ce monsieur je le
disais que c'était toujours sur vos
écrans le numéro à droite de l'écran qui
est appelé en premier
klein daniel strasbourg est ce que le
schmilblick se rencontrent sur le bord
des routes
le schmilblick ne se rencontrent pas sur
le bord des routes ou alors il faudrait
une circonstances tout à fait
exceptionnelles je crois
évidemment si je précisais la situation
exceptionnelle qui pourrait faire que la
chine bric se rencontrent au bord des
routes ça vous mettrait sur la voie mais
la sanef suscite une petite seconde de
réflexion si vous permettez de vous
répondre daniel je vais prendre conseils
de jean marc alors nous remonterons
chimiques à l'image
[Musique]
je reviens à strasbourg après ce petit
temps de réflexion puisque c'est la
première question qui nous a mis un peu
en difficulté ce qui prouve qu'elle
était très précise alors nous vous
autorisons à notre donner le nom d'un
schmilblick à quoi pensez-vous
je pensais ça n'est pas cela je suis
désolé pour vous mais néanmoins puisque
vous avez posé une question positive se
voir le plaisir de m si vous le
permettez 100 francs de plus dans la
cagnotte est maintenant le schmilblick
pour 200 francs et nous passons
maintenant aux candidats aux concurrents
strasbourgeois où ça a l'air de très
bien se passer numéro 7 pour l'énergie
le père strasbourg est ce que le
schmilblick s'achète dans un débit de
tabac
à ce jeu c'est à dire que non je ne
crois pas x qui connaît là je me levais
il va pas du tout comment on pourra
acheter ça dans un débit de tabac mais
par curiosité à quoi pensiez-vous une
cigarette
non non ce n'est pas cela monsieur sous
l'éclat et bien en votre honneur nous en
fumant une tout à l'heure bonsoir
monsieur aux concurrents suivants le
numéro six mois sportif est ce que je
peux me servir un schmilblick nous avait
pas dit votre nom monsieur d'abord
monsieur corollaire auray morbihan
quel est votre prénom jacky la bretagne
en alsace et quel est le sport que vous
pratiquez monsieur tous un peu de tout
non je ne crois pas que voulez vous ayez
jamais eu l'occasion de pratiquer un
sport avec le schmilblick vous savez je
ne crois pas non merci monsieur
excusez-nous est encore à bientôt
numéro 4 maintenant monsieur votre nom
de boersch neverland gérard de
schiltigheim
est-ce que vous monsieur guy lux vous
servez du schmilblick la cgt s'était pas
mise en scène écoutez je n'ai pas
l'impression gésiers tout à l'heure
ayant découvert le nom du schmilblick
qui avait été tenu secret par ceux qui
l'ont découvert
jusqu'à la dernière seconde j'essayais
de me souvenir si j'avais pu me servir
la chemise bic ou si j'en avais
rencontré honnêtement j'en ai peut-être
rencontrer un comme je les dis au début
d'ailleurs de cette émission on en a
peut-être tous vu à et certains en voit
tous les jours mais moi personnellement
je vous le dis jamais et vous sûrement
pas à moins que vous ne donniez votre
métier votre métier monsieur schnoebelen
agents commencent à jean-louis un genre
alors tu es présent relation me rends
pas alerté par ce public
merci monsieur d'être venu nous voir
candidat numéro 12 le numéro suivant
monsieur ou madame c'est monsieur
partait vraiment strasbourg est ce que
le schmilblick ses troupes dans les
champs le schmilblick ne se trouve pas
dans les chambres 1 je pense que quand
vous parlez achats de chant par les ca
ch amps n'est ce pas très bien non
monsieur n'ont absolument pas désolé un
autre le candidat numéro 12 c'est une
candidate strasbourg alors on est chez
eux que le schmilblick se met autour du
cou à la coquetterie féminine voyez eh
bien madame regarder à nouveau ce
schmilblick là et dites moi si vous
pouvez vous mettre ça autour du cou
c'est quand même surprenant
vous avez un sens de la coquetterie et
c'est assez curieux madame non je ne
vois pas du tout la schmilblick dont il
est question autour de votre cou madame
j'en suis désolé pour vous et c'est
dommage parce qu'ils vont maintenant 200
francs au concurrent numéro 18 qui est
une concurrente madame ou mademoiselle
madame aubry dit est ce que je pourrais
soulevé le schmilblick à question en
plein d'astuces plein d'astuces vous
permettez on va remontrer le schmiblick
et je vais finalement posé cette
question parce que c'est une question de
poids finalement combien pèse le
schmilblick ça je n'ignore je pense donc
question de jean-marc
méditons effectivement vous pourriez
soulevé le schmilblick
alors vous êtes autorisé maintenant a
précisé le nom du schmilblick auquel
vous pensez et immédiatement jeu mais
sans prendre plus dans la cagnotte si
vous répondez bien vous en planter 300
francs eh bien je pense à une borne
kilométrique
pourquoi vous avez l'habitude de porter
les bagages et l'amérique à settat y
canela à vous déplacer les kilomètres
français ça les bassa sherman basel
merci en tous les cas de votre charmant
sourire et de votre intervention
concurrentes ou concurrents numéro 10
est monsieur henri jean pierre du
strasbourg est ce que le schmilblick et
vivant non le schmilblick n'est pas
vivant je suis désolé jean pierre à
bientôt concurrent numéro 16
c'est encore un jeune homme sait faire
est ce que le public sert à travailler
oui monsieur oui je mets le blick sert à
travailler
c'est un instrument de travail et
j'aimerais que immédiatement alors que
on me fait signe en régie faut que je
m'habitue à ce petit jeu voyez moi je
suis pas généreux je veux pas mettre
d'argent dans la cagnotte
j'avais s'en prend le plus maintenant il
ya 400 francs après par son jumeau sur
un morceau de craie ah oui effectivement
oui si on va revoir le schmilblick une
fois s'il vous plaît justement on
pourrait penser que c'est un morceau de
craie montrer le oui non monsieur ce
n'est pas cela désolé en tous les cas
vous avez fait monter la cagnotte des
schmilblick merci aux concurrents
suivants 15 petit jean marc de
strasbourg est ce que le public est-il
conducteur du courant électrique
petit jean marc de strasbourg le
schmilblick n'a rien à voir avec le
courant électrique
je suis désolé concurrent numéro 14 une
très jeune concurrente argué lille
strasbourg elle que le schmilblick sert
aux menuisiers ce héros menuisier aux
menuisiers non la demoiselle
le public ne sert absolument pas
menuisier concurrents aux concurrentes
numéro il reste encore très peu de
concurrence je crois qu'ils luxe
approché bien regarder les un tout petit
peu plus longtemps puisque nous sommes
tellement heureux de retrouver nos amis
geeks attendait monsieur n'a pas entendu
votre nom je crois frei ce monsieur
price est ce que le schmilblick est un
monument
non monsieur non non vraiment pas un
monument effectivement d'ailleurs
regardez le à nouveau monsieur fraysse
regardez le schmilblick
on pouvait penser que c'était à bout de
cigarettes que ça pouvait être en effet
une borne kilométrique mais comme
monument c'est assez rudimentaire ça
n'est pas un monument monsieur fraysse
et nous passons aux concurrents suivants
qui est également un très jeune
concurrent quand tu appelles tu leur
hausse à l'aps patrick et puis de
strasbourg est le chimique le schmiblick
sert aux médecins ah non non non non
petit ami non le schmilblick ne sert pas
du tout aux médecins n'est ce pas jean
marc je ne crois vraiment pas que jamais
un médecin se soit servi de schmilblik
ou h même très précis je crois que
jamais un médecin ne s'est jamais servi
d'un schmilblick
merci d'être venus et le concurrent sud
ans et sa maman je crois à dont il était
avec sa maman c'est pour ça qu'il avait
la paix russes allaient demander à maman
de lui son jeu dans l'eau pendant 20
mois que non je crois que l'amendement
n'est pas du tout intervenus ma dans
cette aventure
jean marc est déjà parti vous savez
c'est pareil on me dit qu'il n'ya plus
que trois concurrents nous avons
quelques concurrents supplémentaires en
avons quatre 50 au lieu de montrer
monsieur guy lux feriez mieux de montrer
le schmilblick mon cher ami je n'ai rien
à ce public
voilà très bien ah et bien en tous les
cas gérard brianti désolé les trois
derniers concurrents ne pourront même
pas passé vous savez que nous sommes
dans un carcan horaire extrêmement
précis et nous n'avons que 12 minutes il
est quand même passé pas mal de
concurrents je crois que nous pouvons
résumer rapidement que ce n'est ni un
monument ni un bout de cigarettes que ça
ne sert pas docteur qui s'interpose
sportif d'ailleurs de toute façon demain
au début de l'émission ce sera notre
premier souci de bien résumé tout cela
vous savez que ce soir grâce à quatre
interventions brillante notre
schmilblick est arrivé à 400 francs
d'ailleurs nous allons montrer à nouveau
le schmilblick et le prix qu'il a
atteint 400 francs vous avez compris le
principe malheur extrêmement simple
biblique de ce je vous posais une
question si elle est bonne je vous
autorise à donner le nom d'un
schmilblick et si vous donnez le
véritable nom vous emporter le montant
de la cagnotte
demain je crois jean-marc que nous
jouons avec nos amis de bordeaux et bien
rendez vous à bordeaux c'est merveilleux
nous faisons tous les soirs à tour de
france le schmilblick est parti pour un
tour de france j'ai l'impression qu'il
risque de tenir longtemps
commencez vous même à bien surveiller
cette image sur laquelle nous allons
nous séparer et demain à bordeaux je
suis sûr que déjà le problème va se
resserrer
merci de votre attention merci l'alsace
bonsoir strasbourg bonsoir la france à
demain avec notre schmilblick 400 francs
et bonne chance à tous
[Musique]